Bruce let me start with UCLA firing Jim
Mora why now well if you hope to get
into Chip Kelly sweepstakes you're gonna
make a big swing at him and I think they
knew Florida had already had some had
gotten some traction there with chip and
this is really the big fish out there in
this coaching coaching cycle I mean
talking about a guy who went forty six
and seven and four years at Oregon
arguably the most innovative offensive
mind in all of football and he's worked
in the pac-12 had a lot of success here
so I think that was that's the chance to
say hey what's the one thing we can do
that can really put a real scare into
our archrival USC and that's go get Chip
Kelly do you think it felt like it was a
fait accompli that more was going to be
fired at the end of the year but if UCLA
beats USC they're not firing Jim Mora
are they if this same scenario presents
itself that Florida is you know up on
Chip Kelly's doorstep in New Hampshire
yeah I think that's very hard to do you
fire him after he beats the archrival
and by the way he'd beaten him three
years and you know in his first three
years there so I think that's that's a
hard sell then maybe you look at it okay
well going forward he's got it changes
defensive staff because they've been
awful you know on the defensive side of
the ball or make some adjustments there
but in this case again this is such a
big move for them to make and we're
talking about a school that doesn't
really throw around that much money
they're gonna have to pay amyl gym more
they have to pay him over 12 million
dollars the other big plus with Chip
Kelly here as you're getting a such a
big value coach if you can get him where
he's already getting paid so much money
by the San Francisco 49ers that it
mitigates a lot of a lot of the costs
that it would come on on to you on the
front end of it how does Florida go to
Chip Kelly's house in New Hampshire and
not come back with Chip Kelly you know
Dan I was told this by a source that
they were not expected it was never part
of the plan that he was gonna be on the
plane coming back you know this wasn't
the first meeting that they had
with with Kelly but you know I think he
wants to do things he's not gonna this
is gonna be this his last you know big
move part of his career and I think he
wants to really get this sorted out a
hundred percent in his head before he
before he makes his decision it's going
to be on his time and so I think he
wants to be a hundred percent on it and
look I think he knows Florida is a great
job you know you have a huge huge
recruiting pool you have good resources
you have a program that's won national
titles with multiple coaches the the
question is is it the most comfortable
fit for him you know I think there's
some other big SEC jobs and quite
honestly I don't think Chip Kelly would
want any part of either because of the
leadership you know on top of them that
he's not he wouldn't be comfortable with
or just the fishbowl quality of it
Florida doesn't have as much of that
fishbowl quality and from everything I
had heard coming out of this meeting
that that both sides felt it went very
well for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]